[Music]
and I was living my dream
[Music]
first of all could we talk about this
amazing finale look I mean this is a
glow up Susan you how do you feel on it
yeah you really do you about what event
you were coming to tonight right as
basic sightings but this fun yeah you
know it's full of surprises children to
find out I was gonna say what has this
experience meant to you being able to
share your talent across the pond cuz of
course we know you from Britain's Got
Talent but how has America embraced you
the great people it's great to be here
was there any added pressure knowing
that you'd be going up going up against
other champions of this show I'll tell
you what though Mel B saw something in
you early on you're her golden buzzer on
what piece of advice has Mel giving you
in this journey to keep going yeah
that's right it's all about the fun
you're a a GT um what has been the best
part about it meeting simon cuz yeah
he's psycho he's really nice is a very
kind to thank you saying
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]